just want to make a quick announcement
video for the next chess perament that
I'll be competing I arrived in the
country of kar the day before yesterday
and starting in about 8 hours from this
recording is round one of the K Masters
this is going to be the strongest
tournament I've ever played by far let
me show the player list we can see it's
super super sacked on top with Magnus
hikaro Anish gukesh the list goes on and
on uh there's well over 50 Grand Masters
competing in this event uh you do have
to scroll pretty far down to find my
name I will leave a link to the player
list in the video description but I'm
seated
130 out of 160 players so hopefully like
every round I'll be playing higher rated
competition and it's going to be a
challenge but at the same time I think
this will take the pressure off and I
think it'll be a big accomplishment to
play anyone in the top 10 I do like how
they flag the junior players to make me
feel old and weak but um yeah I've never
actually played the same tournament as
hakaru or Magnus so to be competing in
the same section as um in a Fed like
over the word classical tournament is
really something
special and yeah what more to say uh I
do plan to make daily YouTube Recaps of
every game I play Win Lose or Draw so
stay tuned for those also the one and
only Jonathan shr is coming back to take
over my twitch Channel
twitch.tv/ amrosen there's a game a day
I'll show the playing schedule here
every day 300 p.m. local time there's
also going to be a live broadcast from
for the official YouTube channel which I
actually just found it's linked from the
chess results page they only have 14
subscribers but I think they're putting
in a lot of resources to produce a nice
live show so be sure to follow their
Channel I'll leave a link in the video
description I'll leave links to
everything in the video description so
hopefully there's a lot of ways to watch
and enjoy the tourment online and yeah I
think that's all I want to say actually
I want to share a quick Side Story
before I end the video cuz a few days
ago I posted a photo on my Instagram
story that confused a lot of people this
was a photo taken by Leonard UTS at the
US Championship opening ceremony and if
you look really closely in this photo
you'll see that I got the GM title
except I'm not a GM whoever made the
name tags I think just got confused or
wanted to mess with me but um hopefully
this is a sign of good things to come uh
for those wondering I don't have any GM
Norms uh my current fed rating is
2341 so I'm pretty far away from the
title I need three norms and a 2500
rating to get the title but who knows if
I do well enough in this event there are
definitely chances to achieve a norm but
again my focus is to hopefully just play
good moves and have fun and learn as
much as possible so with that I do look
forward to just playing chess for the
next 10 days and stay tuned for the
Recaps and I'll see you guys soon